- Welcome, everyone.
I'm really glad to see
everybody here in Luce Hall,
as well as virtually via Zoom
to our very special talk this afternoon.
So, my name is Steven Wilkinson,
I'm the Nilekani Professor
of Indian South Asian Studies
here at Yale
and the Faculty Director
of the MacMillan Center.
So, the MacMillan Center
is Yale's focal point
for the study of cultures,
societies, languages
around the world.
We train our students
to understand the world,
to understand the world's languages.
We send them out in the world to learn.
And we also have the opportunity
to bring distinguished
visitors here to Yale
so that we may learn from them here.
Now, I'm really delighted today
to introduce our featured speaker,
the Mayor of Warsaw, Rafał Trzaskowski
and our moderator, Professor Marci Shore,
who's also the director
of graduate studies
for our very active
European and Russian studies
NA Program at the
European Studies Council.
And Marci organized this event.
So, Mayor Trzaskowski's
title for today's talk,
is War in Ukraine and a
New Trans-Atlantic agenda.
This event is being supported
by the George Herbert Walker Jr.
lecture fund in international studies
here at the MacMillan Center.
So this was fund established
in honor of Burt Walker
by the Walker family.
The Walker family has
produced both Bush Presidents
who were Yale graduates
are a part of that family.
So, I'm about to note that the mayor
is delivering one of our first
in-person Walker lectures
since 2019.
Mayor Trzaskowski has been the
Mayor of Warsaw since 2018.
He's a member of the
European Committee of Regions
and the board of Eurocities.
In 2020, he was the
civic platforms candidate
for the presidency of Poland.
He's a former member of
the European Parliament,
vice chair of the European people's party.
And in 2014, he served
as the deputy minister
of foreign affairs of
the Republican Poland.
And in 2013, as a minister
for administration
and digitization
in the cabinet of the former
prime minister of Poland,
Donald Tusk.
Mayor Trzaskowski was born in Warsaw,
where he studied at graduated
from the University of Warsaw.
In 2004, he obtained his Ph.D.
degree in political science.
He speaks fluent English,
French, Spanish, Russian,
and Italian.
And moderating his talk today,
is professor Marci Shore.
Professor Shore teaches Modern
European Intellectual History
here at Yale.
Her research focuses on
the intellectual history
of 20th and 21 century
Central and Eastern Europe.
She has written many things.
She's the translator of Michał
Głowiński, The Black Seasons,
the author of Caviar and Ashes,
Warsaw Generation's Life and
Death in Marxism, 1918-1968.
The Taste of Ashes,
The Afterlife of Totalitarianism
in Eastern Europe,
and The Ukrainian Night,
an intimate history of revolution.
She was also in 2018,
a recipient at the very
prestigious Guggenheim Fellowships
for her current book project.
So, thank you to Marci for
moderating today's talk.
The format today is gonna be this,
we're gonna hear from
Mayor Trzaskowski first
and then professor Shore
and Mayor Trzaskowski will
sit up front for a discussion
and a Q&A session.
That'll give people the opportunity
to ask them whatever you like.
Thank you both, and thank
you all for joining us
this afternoon.
(audience clapping)
- Yes, hello, good afternoon.
(speaking in foreign language)
It is a honor and a privilege
to be here at the Yale
and have an opportunity to talk to you
about what's happening
right now in my country
and in my region, of course.
And to talk about the Trans
Atlantic Relationship.
And of course, what kind of
impact the situation of today
has on Trans Atlantic relations.
I mean, first of all,
I have to tell you that as
it was mentioned before,
I started in European Policy
and I was a think tanker
for quite a long time
and a university lecturer
and I still am at St.
Petersburg University,
dealing mostly with the European affairs.
And I worked in the European Parliament.
I was a member of the European Parliament
and was a minister of
European Integration.
And then I moved into national politics.
Some people say one of the
biggest mistakes of my life.
(audience laugh)
And I was a minister
and then I was a member
of National Parliament.
And then I moved to local government.
This is pretty unusual
because usually it's the other way round.
You start with local government,
then you do national,
then maybe European later on.
And of course, everyone was telling me,
listen, I mean, finally
that's a job of your life
because you can focus on the future.
You can actually start building
and modernizing your city.
And of course, everything
you do will leave an impact
because that's what
happens when you're a mayor
of a wonderful city.
And Warsaw of course, is a wonderful city.
And you will just focus
on modernizing your city.
And on top of that,
you will not be subjected
to the political bickering
and partisanship because
people will just simply...
National media will forget
about you for a while.
And only when there's a small crisis,
maybe they will be reminded of you.
And I thought yeah,
well, it's worth a try.
And of course, I'm born and bred Warsaw,
so of course, that was quite a challenge.
After I became mayor, boom,
a sewer pipe burst under the Vista River.
And by the way, it burst twice.
So of course, I was mostly
focusing my attention to that.
And with the crazy governmental place
and with the propaganda
that they've unleashed,
it was not easy.
And then when we just
got after the crisis,
after the first crisis
when he got out of that,
of course, COVID hit us.
Four waves of it.
And just as we were getting
out of it, a war happened,
which obviously gives
you quite a perspective
and sometimes I introduce
myself, not as a mayor of Warsaw,
but as a minister of crisis situations,
because all the time, you
have to deal with the crisis,
but that's politics for
you, politics of today.
But of course, what
happens in Ukraine today
is incredibly serious.
And it has huge implications
for the security of the region,
but also for the security of the world.
And that's why we need to
seriously talk about that.
And the thing is that we
were warning our friends
in Europe and also in America for years.
And we were observing
Vladimir Putin's career,
and for us at least, it was pretty clear
who are we dealing with.
So we were not misled even at
the beginning of the century
that this guy could be a good Democrat,
because it was just enough
to study his days in KGB.
To study his days in Petersburg
to sort of guess what
kind of people are we...
What kind of guy we are dealing with.
And we were telling our friends in Europe
and we were telling
our friends in America,
don't do deals with thugs or that least,
think about security.
Think about making Poland and
making Europe more independent
from fossil fuels coming from Russia.
Think about putting our energy
into any democratic endeavor
you can,
which is going to strengthen our neighbors
to the East of Poland,
to the so-called post service sphere.
Because our Ukrainian friends
are more than friends,
at the beginning, even our
fellow Russian friends,
were striving towards democracy.
And of course, everyone was in the U.S.,
but sometimes even in Europe,
everyone was sort of lumping
us together as Eastern European
and thinking that we are no different.
Well, we are, because of course,
we have quite different
democratic experiences,
but we all wanted the same thing.
We wanted to be peaceful,
stable, democratic nations.
And by the way, Ukraine was promised that
when it decided to give
its nuclear weapons away.
It was guaranteed by the Western powers
that the integrity and
sovereignty of Ukraine
will be protected.
And later on, we were trying all the time
to convince our friends
in Europe and in the U.S.
that we should at least buy that security,
build an energy union.
I will explain in a second what it is.
Build a strong eastern
policy of the European Union.
I remember I started working
in the European Parliament
in 2004, just when Orange Revolution hit
and everyone was hyped up for a while.
And then we said, "Okay,
now is the to build
the energy union."
And in a few months, I
mean, the attention went
and people started thinking
about something different.
And again, we've heard the same spiel.
Come on Europe, you're
obsessed with Russia.
I mean, there's such reliable partners,
even in the Soviet times,
when it came to gas,
when it came to oil, we could rely on them
and we could do business with them.
And now with new Russia, why not?
And many people were saying,
if you are investing in
the future of Ukraine,
investing in the future of Moldova,
trying to promise them,
European Union membership,
not mentioning any security guarantees,
then you are actually undermining
the security of Europe.
And you were saying, you
are dealing with thugs.
You are dealing with
guys who just understand
the language of power.
And all the time we've
heard, you are obsessed.
You don't understand the modernity
because you're just
there in Eastern Europe
not seeing the bigger picture.
But fortunately, we were
able to prepare ourselves
at least a bit for what was to come.
Look at energy union, it
was an idea of Donald Tusk,
our former prime minister.
It was supported of
course, by our politician.
It was realized by our governments.
Also when I was minister
of European affairs.
And before we were doing quite a lot
in the European Parliament.
And what we did, for example,
we made steps to make sure that
we would building energy terminals
so that we could import gas.
What we did, we did inverse flow.
Okay, and the so-called inter connectors,
which means that just what
10 years ago, 15 years ago,
gas and oil could just flow
one way from Russia to Europe.
Now, we can do the reverse.
We started building inter
connectors with the Baltic States,
with Slovakia, the Czech
Republic, so on and so forth,
so that we could transport
oil and gas throughout Europe.
We also invested in big
reserve wars of gas.
And now it's an obligation
to have those reserve wars
for at least three months.
And we've also strengthened
the competition policy
of the European Union so that
you can go after gas problem
when it is breaking the
rules of competition.
We've decoupled two very important things.
One is extraction of oil and
then the distribution of oil
and gas, right?
So at least because of our insistence,
we are better prepared
to what's happening.
I mean, as you know just
yesterday Russia cut gas
to Poland and to Bulgaria.
And similarly and simultaneously,
we were strengthening
the Eastern dimension
of the European Union.
Investing a lot in those links
with our friends to the east.
And it was tough, boy, it was tough.
And I remember talking to
our friends, negotiating it,
and of course, so many hurdles on the way.
And if you mentioned north stream,
one north seemed to the pipeline gas pipe
under the Baltic Sea.
We were warning our friends,
listen, don't get too
much dependent on Russia.
And again, our arguments were not heard
by our German friends
and they were telling us
it's a business enterprise.
You shouldn't be so insistent.
And then what?
And then of course,
history proved us right.
And of course, this is a
very bitter pill to swallow.
And now we have a crisis on our hands
and a crisis of global dimensions.
What happens is that of
course, Putin has miscalculated
because he thought first of all,
that he would be able to
divide the Ukrainian society.
He thought that the Ukrainian
society will be divided,
that many troops will desert.
That his army will be able
to actually take over Kyiv
in a few days.
He thought that he's going to divide us
because he was remembering 2014
when we've agreed on sanctions,
but they were not very serious.
And again, I was negotiating them.
And when we were telling our friends,
we thought these sanctions
need to be serious.
We need to go after the oligarchs.
We need to do something about gas and oil.
Again, they were saying,
no, no, no, no, no, no.
Step by step.
And of course, Putin thought
that with such a weak response
to Russian aggression in 2014,
he thought that he could do it again.
And that's what his
intelligence was telling him.
So, the incredible
thing is that of course,
he miscalculated when it comes to Ukraine,
because it turned out that
we have a united response.
And by the way, I was
just four or five days
before the war I was in Kyiv.
And even there people were telling me,
well, yeah, maybe 20%, 30% of
Ukrainian troops will dessert,
or maybe they will not listen to orders.
There will be two or three
important regional leaders
who might desert.
Nothing of this sort happened.
And the Ukrainians
really did their lesson.
I mean, we've got no time to
go into the military aspects
of it, but really, I mean, after 2014,
they've learned their lesson.
I mean, my favorite thing
is that there is an app.
If you are a citizen of
Ukraine, you have that app,
which is used to communicate
with the government.
And now it was turned into an app
on which you can inform about
Russian troop movements.
Make pictures, maps, and
so on and send it directly
to the authorities and no one can fake it
because if you don't
have a Ukraine identity,
you can't operate that.
And the Russians,
they were supposed to have
brilliant communication devices
after the Georgian War.
Now of course, they're using cell phones,
because Putin has created the kleptocracy.
I mean, these guys were just
stealing from government.
They were not investing
in modern equipment.
And they're fantastic
at doing little mischief
and hybrid warfare and tactical movement.
But it turned out that they're
not that good at strategy.
Thanks God.
So that's the lesson we are learning,
and of course, we should be learning more.
Now he has also miscalculated
when it comes to us,
but most importantly,
he's miscalculated when it
comes to the civil society
and the power of the social media.
Because I mean, this fight
that we are observing is epic,
and it's so clear.
It's like David and Goliath.
It's a biblical proportions,
and it's so clear who's a
good guy, who's a bad guy.
Sometimes comparing it
for my American audience
to your pop culture.
You have like this marvel
comic ultimate evil,
fighting this every American,
every man who suddenly turns into a hero.
Okay? It's so clear.
And that's why the response
of the civil society,
the response of all of us
was so clear and so strong.
And the pressure exerted on
elected leaders was so strong.
If someone were to tell me two months ago
that so many American companies
would go out of Russia,
so many German, European companies,
I wouldn't have believed hadn't I seen it.
But of course, that's also
because of the pressure
of the civil society.
And here, again, Putin has miscalculated
because he doesn't understand it.
And again, it brings us to
the same same thesis that,
this fight is so clear.
In 2014, it wasn't so clear
or we didn't tell this story well.
The narrative was a bit different.
And he's miscalculated when
it comes to our response,
because finally the European Union,
the United States of
America started responding
in a concerted and in a tough way.
Because these sanctions bite.
For the first time, we
went after the oligarchs.
For the first time,
we were talking about
getting ourselves seriously independent
when it comes to Russian fossil fuels.
And we were taking some tough decision.
Can we do more?
Yes, we can.
Those sanctions can be even tougher,
but Swift, oil and gas,
American and European companies
out to Russia, that's huge.
And of course, you can always think about
whether the glass half full or half empty,
but I think that it was
pretty surprising for Putin.
And of course, we need to do more.
And the important thing is
that we have to persevere.
that we cannot simply think
that it's going to end soon
and that then we can relent.
And of course,
we are facing one of the biggest
refugee crisis in history
in Europe,
but also in the world
after the Second World War.
You know that just three months ago,
Poland was 120th when it
came to accepting refugees,
some people said 105th
because there are different statistics.
Now we are second, soon to be first.
That shows you the
magnitude of the problem.
If you remember the Mediterranean crisis,
when Europe was panicking,
Barb Wire and so on,
and people running a mock,
not knowing how to respond.
We had 200,000 people at a peak,
200,000 people coming to Europe.
We have 300,000 people
who came to Warsaw alone
in a matter of a month.
So, that shows you the
magnitude of the problem.
And of course, refugees are
vulnerable people by definition,
but we have the most vulnerable
because these are usually
mostly young women with kids.
I have 120,000 kids in Warsaw.
I have 280,000 kids in my schools.
And because we have granted courageously,
we've granted Ukrainians
citizen like status,
they have access to free education,
to free healthcare and to
free social protection.
That means that we should
be accepting 120,000 kids
to our schools.
We have enrolled already 20,000.
And now we come to the most important part
of my message to you, is that
what we should do with it.
I mean, the most important thing
is that there's no strategy, guys.
There's no strategy on a Polish level.
There's no strategy on a European level.
There's no strategy on
an international level.
Most of what you see is improvisation.
Most of what you see is
not miraculous government,
central government dealing with it.
It's the people.
The people have accepted
Ukraine to their homes.
Most of us in Poland,
you don't see, I mean,
people come from the U.S.,
from Europe, from different
places, special migration.
And they're amazed.
They say, okay, where are the refugees?
Because there are no refugee
camps, huge refugee camps.
There are no pitch dances in parks.
There are no people in the streets
because they're at our homes.
But of course, the
solidarity which is amazing
cannot be kept without a
strategy for months and years
because people accepted Ukrainians
for two, three, four months,
but not for eight or nine.
Of course, some of them,
most of them stay with their
friends and with their family.
So they can, because we had
a huge Ukrainian diaspora
in Poland before that.
But some of them stay
with complete strangers.
So we need a strategy.
We need a relocation scheme in Europe
where it will be coordinated
by the European Union
where different countries made pledges.
And then someone needs to coordinate it.
Because a month ago, I was calling...
In the middle of the night
I was calling different mayors
from Poland and from Europe
and telling them, please
take 300, take 200 guys,
send us a few buses because
we were overwhelmed.
And this government is
not asking for a strategy
and it is not authorizing
the European Union to work
because of course,
they want to get all the political credit.
And I keep telling them guys
no government will be able
to deal with such a crisis.
And of course, that's why we
need a push from the Americans,
from our European friends
in order to have a strategy,
because we have lots of UN
agencies working on the ground.
We have European agencies
working on the ground,
but this haphazard, it's piecemeal,
because the government is
just picking this service,
this help and so on.
We are having our own strategy in Warsaw,
but that's not enough.
Because if I have a
strategy about education,
I told the minister of education,
guys, we cannot accept
120,000 kids overnight.
Most of them should do distance learning
on a Ukrainian platform.
And that's what the Ukrainian
Education Ministry want,
right?
That makes more sense.
But there's no strategy.
So we are doing it ourselves.
In Warsaw, we are enrolling
people to our schools,
but we are also building those places
in which they can learn online.
We are getting equipment
from donors and so on.
But of course,
because Warsaw is also
the only city in Poland
which has preschools for free
because that was of my electoral program,
that creates a huge pull factor.
And again, without a strategy,
it's going to be very
difficult to deal with that.
So strategy, strategy, strategy,
both on a national and a European level.
We have done a lot in the European Union
to regulate the status of refugees.
But these guys,
according to the European
law are not refugees.
They are displaced people in
need of temporary protection,
different directives apply.
So, again, I'm gonna give you an example,
if you're a refugee and if
you get registered in Poland,
if you go to Germany, then
you lose any social protection
because the European Union wants to fight
with secondary movements
and with a possibility
to choose the country of your asylum,
because that would mean that
everyone would go to Germany
or to Sweden because that's
where the conditions are best.
But these guys, again, are not refugees.
So for example, they ask me if I register,
do I lose my social rights,
if then I go to the
Netherlands or to Germany?
And I cannot answer them
because we don't have a
one system Europe on that.
So, that's why we need
a European strategy.
And I could go on and on and
give you some other examples
of that.
And of course, when it comes to support,
we need that support
not only to go to the central government,
but we need that support
to go to the non-governmental
organizations.
By the way, exactly the same
non-governmental organizations
that now save our day,
were the ones that were
deprived of financing
by the populist government,
those who help with refugees,
those who help with women's
rights, children trafficking,
LGBT community and so on and so forth.
Those are the guys who are now helping us
and now are saving the day.
So the money should go to refugees,
to non-government
organizations and also to us.
And that's also the message
that I'm trying to sell
in Europe and to our American friends.
And now finally, in the last
few minutes about job politics,
because everyone is
asking the same questions,
what's gonna happen?
We don't know what's gonna happen.
And you've heard because I
assume that you are interested
in what's happening if you're here.
You heard Putin in just
yesterday saying that
they might escalate that those myths,
that there is a Polish American plot
to send our soldiers into
Ukraine and so on and so forth.
This is really worrying.
And of course, these guys
are threatening to escalate.
They're escalating already in the east.
They're threatening to
maybe go to another level,
but I tell you one thing, I
mean, the thugs and bullies,
and some of us know it
from our neighborhood
and from our high school
understand only the word of strength
or the reality of strength.
So we need to stay united.
We need to send clear signals to Russia.
We shouldn't lose it from sight,
because again,
I'm afraid that after two,
three, four, five months,
people will turn their attention
to something different.
And of course, the end game
is very difficult to foresee
because maybe Putin is looking
for a face saving exercise.
We don't know, but what if he finds one
and then it's unacceptable
to our Ukrainian friends?
What do we do then?
And of course, what do
we do with the crisis
which is at our hands,
the humanitarian crisis,
because we've opened our
Ukrainian brothers and sisters
and we will keep on doing so,
but we probably are going
to have a second wave
of just three or four days ago.
No, five days ago, before coming here,
I talked to people from Donbas
and they were telling me
we were there for seven, eight years
in the war zone and we didn't move.
But after what we've seen in Bucha happen,
we decided to move, and
they're moving to Poland.
So, of course, we cannot do it alone
and we need assistance and we need help.
And of course, that has huge
implications for our security.
There's always a silver lining
because the important stuff
is also that the century
of historical experiences
can be turned overnight
and we can build a much
sounder and better foundation
for our relations with
our Ukrainian friends.
This is incredibly important
for the stability of the region
and for the chance of those
posts of states to be integrated
to the European community.
But the important thing is,
also that some of them
will stay in Poland.
Many of them will go back
with completely different expectations,
building a democratic state.
I meet them on the ground
and at the beginning,
and I speak Russian.
So it's a bit more easy.
And they look at me and
I tell them I'm a mayor.
I want to help and so on in Russia
and most of them don't believe me.
A mayor at a railway station
with no security guards speaking to me
and everything's for free?
We need to ask our Ukraine volunteers
to explain that this is not a scam,
that I don't want to cheat
them out of their money.
But these expectations will
be carried back, we hope.
And that will allow our Ukrainian friends
to create a democratic society in Ukraine.
So, that's the positive angle to it.
But of course, still this
huge geopolitical problem
is ahead of us.
And we need to get our heads
together and try to resolve it.
And it's not gonna be easy.
So, I'll stop here, guys,
because I know that you
want to probably ask
quite a few questions and Marci as well,
so that we can move
fluidly to the second part.
And I always finish all my lectures,
all my talks the same way
today in this day and age.
(speaking in foreign language)
(audience speaking in foreign language)
- I have the feeling of a tear in time
that you have a dramatic
historical moment,
the sense that one world has ended,
and whatever happens next,
we're going to be in another world.
A couple days before the invasion started,
our friend Svyatoslav Vakarchuk.
I'm sure you know that Ukrainian rockstar
who spent the semester here at Yale.
So, many of you know him.
I called, and I said,
"Svyatoslav, what is the
atmosphere like in Kyiv?"
And he said, "Well, Marci,
imagine a synthesis between
Florida in October 1961
during the Cuban Missile Crisis
and Central Europe between
the Munich Agreement of 1938,
the invasion of Poland in 1939.
It's something like that."
And there was a sense that
nobody knew what was coming,
but one of the things
that I think Ukrainians
and Poles share is an understanding
that everything is possible.
Americans don't have this.
Americans think their
constraints on reality.
After Trump was elected,
people were walking around
saying, okay, this is bad.
This is very bad, but
we're gonna get through it.
We have checks and balances,
checks and balances was
repeated like a yoga mantra.
Whereas east Europeans,
I feel like know that
everything can look normal,
but it can turn on a dime
and you have to somehow
be prepared for that,
even if it's in pot
possible to be prepared.
So my first question is that
given that tear and time,
what has surprised you most
that you would not have
been able to conceive
of three months ago?
- Well, quite a few things.
I mean, I've just tried to
talk about it for half an hour,
how surprising it was for many
of us at the end of the day,
because we all knew
that something is brewed
and we were also informed about it.
And we took it seriously,
but everyone I talked to,
five days before the war in Kyiv
was telling me it's gonna be
another hybrid war for a bit
but no one expected a
full out war seriously.
I mean, so that of course, was surprising,
but what really surprised me
is this incredible resilience
of the Ukrainian people.
And when they come to
Warsaw, they're so proud.
Most of them just wanna work and they say,
"We do want to rely on anyone.
We just want to earn our upkeep."
And this is incredibly
heartening and amazing.
But also the response,
the concerted and unequivocal
response of the west,
because of this pressure
of the social media,
I mean, if someone were to
tell me, I told you about it,
just two months ago
that this pressure would
be so, so, so important,
I wouldn't believe.
And now the question of course,
is whether that is going to be continued.
And that's a big question.
So there are quite a lot of surprises.
The Polish people didn't surprise me
because after years of
this populous government
who was trying to fight with
and threaten everyone with refugees
and threaten everyone
with the LGBT community
and threaten everyone with
all kinds of minorities,
because they always need an enemy,
I knew that there is this
instinct of solidarity
that we have in our DNA.
By the way,
I negotiated that as a
minister of European affairs,
that we would accept 7,000 refugees
in the Mediterranean crisis.
And the populist government was telling us
that they're going to change
the way we live 7,000.
And at a moment,
7,000 were crossing our
border in 10 minutes.
So that also shows you
the level of manipulation.
It's quite a lot of surprises.
- Okay.
So, I'll ask one more quite
self-interested question,
just that, some of us here
like myself among them,
have been in the role of
the cultural mediators
and the translators, trying
to explain eastern Europe
to Americans.
And if this were an ordinary situation,
I would feel like this is
going extraordinarily well,
we've never gotten so much attention.
The journalists are asking
better and better questions here.
We're better able to connect
our Ukrainian colleagues
with American editors.
And I'm still asking myself,
like what could we do better?
Do you have impression that
there are things here in America
that Americans by and large
don't yet understand well enough
that are crucial, that we
should be on point about?
- Well, again, I mean,
of course, but listen,
I mean, President Biden was in Warsaw
where I had a chance and honor to show him
the place where we register Ukrainians.
And the strongest words possible
about defending every inch
of NATO territory.
I went to the east on numerous occasions
and the Patriot missiles.
I mean, everywhere,
they're American soldiers,
the 82nd, but only everywhere.
I mean, the reality changed so much.
And the response of the Western,
the response and the interest
of the American society's unbelievable.
I mean, listen all my friends
keep asking me, calling me.
I see Ukrainian flags on all social media.
I see in New York, all the Russians,
some of our in vodka places
turning into Ukrainian.
Some of our, in vodka places.
The behavior of celebrities
and so on and so forth.
This is unheard of and
the level of interest.
So, I'm not sure that we can do more.
The important thing that we
draw a lesson from it, okay?
And that we translate it into action.
And that we explain that
this is huge ramifications
for our security.
And by the way, not only
for Russian, Ukraine,
because all the thugs in the world,
all the dictators are looking at it,
and they're thinking, okay.
I mean, the west sometimes
can pull it together
and they can be tough.
They can respond in a uniform fashion.
Okay, maybe being aggressive costs a lot.
Maybe we should rethink it.
I mean, that's also the reality of today.
Let's hope.
So I guess, I've seen all
the American journalists
in Warsaw and really well informed.
I never had so much air
time on American television
in my life, of course.
And it's not only about me,
of course, politicians
always talk about themselves.
Fortunately in America,
you're allowed to do that.
But there is this window
of opportunity to inform,
but also to draw conclusions from, okay?
And to explain what's what
and to explain that we need to be united,
that we need to draw inclusion from it,
to offer Ukraine a European
perspective seriously.
Which would've never happened,
to make ourselves
independent of fossil fuels
coming from Russia.
Today, I was just elected
for the board of the Convent of Mayors
where we fight with climate change.
And I say, this is the
moment where we should seek
for synergies to save our planet,
to fight with climate change,
to make ourselves
independent of fossil fuels
in general and fossil
fuels coming from Russia.
Okay, we need a transition
period, of course.
But because it's not
gonna happen overnight,
but that's should,
I mean, the pandemic
and the crisis in Russia
should push us all of the decision makers
into making the right decisions.
And on top of that,
that also allows us to see who's who.
Remember Trump and how he go sit up
to some Russian politicians.
Remember Salvie Lapan, the
populist government in Poland,
also liking those populists
who were financed by Russia.
I mean, let's not conclusions from it.
Some of them did suddenly like...
Half a year ago, we were
telling the populist in Poland,
why have you removed
all the European flags
from your ministries?
And they're only Polish ones.
By the way, the Polish
flag is the most beautiful
in the world.
(Marci laughs)
But why have you removed
the European ones?
They're back.
All of the European flags are there,
and all the NATO flags are there.
Good. They're learning a lesson.
I mean, so we should
also learn the lesson.
And this is the thing we should be doing,
explaining to the American people,
explaining to the Europeans guys, come on.
Hello, crisis.
Imagine if Trump was president
of the United States now,
Jesus Christ almighty.
(Marci laughs)
People are telling me,
people are asking me,
aren't you afraid?
And I'm saying, if President
Zelensky is not panicking,
I'm not panicking either.
But thanks God we have
the leaders we have.
Imagine Lappen won France.
I mean, we should be drawing conclusions.
The electoral process is not a game,
many people dislike
mainstream political parties.
I understand that.
But at the end of the day,
unfortunately, most of the
time we vote for lesser evil.
Most of the time we need
to vote with our brain
at the end of the day,
not only with our heart.
So this is the point we
should be driving home.
And believe you me, people
understand it in U.S.
Five years ago
when I was talking about
problems with democracy,
I was seeing it in my friend's eyes.
Yeah, this guy from the barren east,
what does he know about democracy?
Trump was elected
and suddenly my American friends
started understanding me,
attack on the Capital,
and everyone understands me.
And by the way,
Poland should be the strongest
democracy in Europe now.
We cannot afford a weakest
link on our eastern border.
So, this is another point
we should be driving home.
And I say it in every conversation
that I have in the U.S.
Now, if someone is undermining democracy,
if someone is undermining the rule of law,
if someone is marginalizing Poland
or any other country
in the European Union,
is doing something
against our most important
national interest,
because we need to be strong,
in Poland, in Hungary,
in Slovenia, in France,
but also of course,
in the United States of America.
So again, maybe I'm just an optimist
but we also have to think
about drawing conclusions
from that.
- Let's take some questions
from the audience.
Jen, I think Jen's also
taking questions from...
- [Jen] Yeah, I also
taking from the audience.
So like I also...
- Let's grab three or four
because I'm a politician.
I love the talk of my voice.
- [Jen] I will hijack agenda here.
I'm from East Ukraine...
- Great.
- [Jen] And first of all, thank you.
I have friends also in
Bucha, and residing right now
and more friends fighting, of course.
And thanks for this thing.
It's also very important,
just a few minutes ago,
U.S. House of Representative
voted to support land lakes.
So like with the landslide for
17 support, which is great.
And you were talking about the...
Well, basically some of the
side of what U.S. actually doing
right now's security for Europe,
security for energy right
now, which is like...
And now there's restorative
terrorism right now
happening from Russian side.
But is there like a core
idea for the strategy,
the strategy of security in Europe?
Because you have Germany as incapacitated
as a United Nations Security Council.
And other few other
countries which are well,
like Hungary and Austria,
which are behaving like
that there nothing happened.
And is there like a core,
one single idea outlying
for this strategy to build security,
both physical on energy side?
Yeah, and I will come
later with the more people
are asking about border
crisis from Belarus.
Yeah, and some part of
my question is also like
how to deter crisis from Russian side,
but I don't think that's this
is like very broad question.
So this is just also about security,
preventing future crisis,
because Russia is not going anywhere.
- Well, I'll try to be telegraphic
because there are three
parts in your question.
So first all, I'll start with Belarus
and so on and so forth.
Guys, because I've been
asked that question
quite a lot on American media as well.
What changed, right?
First of all, we have a
populist government, right?
My government, when I was minister,
we were participating
in European solidarity.
When it came to refugees, we
were able to accept refugees.
What just didn't like was
a mathematical formula
to distribute refugees
according to quotas,
because we thought it was a bad idea.
And it was a bad idea.
Because politically,
you can't simply say,
stand in front of your people and say,
"How many refugees will you accept?"
I don't know.
There is this magical formula
invented by the European
commission, maybe 20,000,
maybe 50,000.
that's a no-go, a non-started.
But we were there building policy.
We were at a high table
negotiating and so on and so forth,
that changed.
Okay?
And of course, as I told you,
the populists always need an enemy.
That was their response to
the Mediterranean crisis.
Now, the Belarusian crisis,
and the border was different
because it was mostly engineered
by Putin and by Lukashenko
who wanted to destabilize Poland.
He wanted to destabilize Europe.
But of course,
again, the populist government
wanted to play a card
and wanted to have a
political win out of that.
So that's why they
started building a wall.
They started behaving in a way
which meant that they
weren't even helping children
who were dying in the woods.
Okay.
But of course, now the situation
is completely different
because everyone understands it,
Ukrainians fight also for our freedom.
And for the first time in years,
there is a bipartisan
agreement that we need to help.
And here on the most part,
we are on the same page
with the government, okay?
It doesn't mean that the
Belarusian problem ceased to exist
because by the way, 8%
of all the three million
who came to Poland are non-Ukrainian,
and it's a hot potato
for the government, okay?
And by the way, when
Ukrainians go to Germany,
they're all welcomed.
But if there is someone with a Nigerian
or Syrian passport there
turned back to Poland,
which also is a problem.
Secondly, when it comes to
your question about divisions
and so on and forth.
Yes, there are divisions, true.
But I mean, again, if
someone were to tell me,
three or four months ago
that lethal weapons would
be provided for Ukrainians
by everyone,
including the Germans.
Okay, after months of organizing
and so on and so forth,
but at least.
Yeah, but they've...
I'm not gonna defend them.
Okay.
I don't want to defend because it's true
that there is no German
leadership at this moment.
It is true that the whole
German political class
disappointed us because we
were telling them repeatedly,
not to do the things that they were doing.
So I'm not gonna defend them,
but hopefully they're
getting their act together.
By the way, because of the greens,
which is one of the biggest
paradoxes of history.
Thank you.
I'm thanking the German green parties
so that there are courageous
and that they know where they
need to adopt their policy.
Okay?
But of course, there are
Hungarians and we know them,
no one knows speaker or better than I do.
And of course, it is a problem.
Although at the end of the day,
they haven't blocked a single decision
of the European Union, the Hungarians,
because this guy's wonderful
at playing different games.
Okay?
Now of course, the question
is, what comes next?
Because we need to start
making ourselves independent
on fossil fuels,
and here at Hungarian say that
they will not allow for that.
And of course, there is this
idea of some of our partners
that they will start paying
Putin in rubles, okay?
So are they in the Euro zone
or are they in the ruble zone?
I don't know.
That's was a tweet of
my party, Donald Tusk,
because it's a pretty apt question.
But again, I mean, it's the
pressure from the people,
which I hope is going to change it, okay?
And it is changing it.
So the only thing is,
and I'm worried about it,
how persistent will we be?
Whether that's not gonna end
in a month or two or three,
What I'm afraid is I'm
afraid about the end game.
What if Putin thinks that, okay,
a part of Donbas is enough
goes (indistinct) and he stops the war.
I'm afraid that then
maybe many of our partners
will say, "Oh, okay, fine, great."
No, it's not gonna be great. Okay?
But of course, we also
need to be realistic.
We need to be cautious,
but we need to be tough.
And if there is an any end game,
first, we need to listen to
President Zelensky, okay?
If it's a hero, he's a
hero, then listen to him.
Okay?
Because I'm afraid then in a few months,
again, there will be a lot
of pressure on the Zelensky.
And I don't want to go back
to the Minsk agreements
and what kind of implications
it had for the security
of Europe and for the future of Ukraine.
Which was by the way, fourth
rammed down the throat
of the Ukraine government by our German
and French colleagues, okay?
But hopefully everyone learns lesson.
And at the end of the day,
seriously, if you were to
tell me two or three weeks,
two or three months ago,
what the response of the west would be,
it's still...
It's pretty surprising that
we got our act together
and that we know what we are doing,
that we are providing weapons and so on.
But of course, we need to
do more that's for sure.
Okay.
- Great.
- Lets grab a few you more.
- Yeah, yeah.
Let's should we take a few together?
- Yeah.
- Okay, so let's see, let's Maximus and...
Okay, so three of you here.
- Just go ahead.
- Yeah, yeah, just go ahead.
- I'll pick off.
So welcome to Yale, good to have you here.
My name's Max, I come from Belarus
(indistinct) far away know
from where you come from.
And you talked a lot about
strategy, an important strategy.
You clearly are a great fan of strategy,
and you still remain the
figure of national politics
in Poland, right?
And not only because of
presidential election
but generally, right?
And I wonder in a little bit
more than a year from now,
you have parliamentary elections
in your country now, right?
And clearly, inflation
will continue to rise.
And even stock filiation
will continue to rise
across European Union,
including Poland.
The immense amount of migration
that we see right now,
and refugees and displaced people
can also cause a certain concern
among popular constituencies in Poland,
if it lasts longer than just
two or three months, right?
And so, there is a certain
reason to think that in 2023,
in fall when the election happen,
but pharma may be in a
very challenging position
that the ground for supportive populism,
support of province populism
can be still substantial.
So what have you learned
since the last elections,
either parliamentary or in presidential
that you will adopt in your
new strategy for your party
and for liberal mind forces in Poland
in order to change the
balance of power in 2023?
- I got you. Two more questions.
- So, hello, my name's (indistinct)
and I have a question about
more of a developmental part
of the energy security
architecture that you mentioned.
So essentially, there
is quite a lot of talk
about accession of Ukraine into the EU.
It's still quite a far road ahead,
especially for the Ukrainians.
And like, as for Russia,
it's pretty much implementing
the Morgan Tower plan 2.0
in which essentially all the Western firms
are withdrawing from Russia,
which is studied at Yale by
Professor Simon and his team.
And essentially we see that
the security infrastructure
in Europe should be,
and the developmental part of
the security infrastructure
in Europe should be emphasized here.
So, how do you see the chances
for Ukraine to join the EU
and the future of age to
potentially to Ukraine after war
and maybe potentially democratic Russia?
- And third question.
- Yeah, thank you for taking the question
and for your time coming out here.
My name is Mitric.
My question is you already started
to touch up on the
previous refugee crisis.
And in your opening remarks,
you mentioned this idea
of building forward.
So you talked about the
energy infrastructure
and you talked about independence, etc,
and being prepared.
So will Poland be prepared
and will Europe create
an infrastructure system
for the next refugee crisis?
So you mentioned certain dissatisfaction
with numbers between 7,000 and 50,000,
while the adults numbers
now are out the door,
because experience proves to us
that we can handle much more than that.
And so when the next crisis comes,
and it's not from Ukraine, but
it's, again, from the more...
Let's say common places
where these crises occur,
will Europe be able to
receive these refugees?
And of course,
with that kind of going to
my friend certain question
with the populist governments,
not just the Polish one,
looking to score points on this,
a lot of the points that have been used
as criticisms for peace, right?
That the LGBTQ rights, women's rights,
judicial reform, etc,
those topics have kind of be compared,
and I think that's probably
integrated in Yale.
They're very happy about that.
So, how do you or what is your plans,
you are a member of your opposition party
to see that those points remain salient
and make sure that Europe is prepared
and is welcoming to be people who happen
to not be Europeans next time?
- Got you.
Okay.
So first of all,
when it comes to the European
perspective for Ukraine,
I mean, that's a very good question
because I think that things have changed
in the heads of a lot
of European politicians.
So for the first time,
because they were telling us
it's impossible.
Ukraine Moldova, not now.
And you've seen the
progress of the negotiations
with the Balkans States
and so on and so forth.
So now it's the moment,
that's the window of
opportunity to speed it up.
Of course, it took us more than a decade
from the first declaration
to actually enter the European Union
from the association agreement
to the membership more than 13 years.
But of course, now is the
moment to drive that point home
and to start the process.
But again, you know for how long
Turkey has been negotiating membership
with the European Union?
From at least 1968.
So, but now's the moment
and that's my answer.
And now we should be driving it
and keeping it on the agenda
of the European Union.
Because that's the only way forward.
And by the way, the
Russians even said NATO,
no European Union, okay.
By the way, you know the
membership in the European Union
would be not much more.
But as serious a guarantee
to the Ukrainians
that they will remain a part
of the west as anything else.
When it comes to what
you said about refugees.
I don't think that
Europe will ever be ready
in a sense that welcoming and so on.
This is the hardest topic ever.
The hot button is you
look at the United States
and so on and forth.
We are better prepared than we used to be.
Because finally, we have
a lot of instruments.
We have the instruments for
helping in the third countries.
We have instruments
when it comes to relocating
immigrants within,
dealing with secondary movements,
we have European border guards.
We've done quite a lot of things
in order to prepare ourselves, okay?
For different type of crises.
We have all of those
readmission agreements.
Finally, we have one
migration policy in Europe
because it used to be
completely fragmented,
but are we prepared?
If we're gonna have millions and millions
of additional refugees,
of course, it always is going
to be a political problem.
And it is politically incorrect to say,
but in a Polish case,
these guys look like us.
They speak a very similar language,
there's this cultural affinity
and they fight for our freedom.
So of course, it is easier to accept that
than to accept someone else.
And of course, it is very
difficult to wage a populist
fight against it because
no one would believe in it.
And even the populist realized that.
So I mean, unfortunately,
I don't think that we will
ever be politically prepared
for that,
but of course, a lot is
changing in people's mentality
because they see that 7,000,
it's not a problem, right?
And of course, the non-Ukrainians,
I said that in my speech,
this is a hot issue for the government,
what to do with them.
And of course, there are
questions of integration.
I mean, now everyone is
saying, Poland did a great job,
but in a month or two or three or four,
if no one help us out,
we will have a backlash.
And then there are questions
that if there is no strategy,
what should I do with 120,000 kids?
I cannot accept them all
to our schools, right?
And then there is a
question of integration,
and then there is a question,
how do we envisage the future?
It's hellishly complicated.
And by the way, if we don't do anything
about climate change,
we're going to have hundreds of,
millions of people on the move.
So that's again, this is a
moment to drive that point home.
Now, about Polish situation.
Well, I could tell you draw
one very important conclusion.
And here I differ from
some of my colleagues,
because I think that we
need to build a bigger tent.
I will submit to you that
we are not going to win
an election without political parties.
And of course, my own civil
platform is a lynchpin of it.
And is the most important, right?
Because it is the most serious.
It is the most experience
that has good people prepared
to govern and so on.
But a lot of people,
especially young people,
dislike mainstream parties.
So, we need to do something about it.
Look at peace and look at the populist.
As we say in Polish, they're
playing in different pianos
at the same time, okay?
So they strengthen the party,
but they were building foundations,
they were building discussion clubs.
They were building internet platforms.
They were doing grassroot movements.
They were doing everything.
And some of my colleagues say
platform, platform, platform.
I love it.
I say, we can chan
together, but I told them,
no, we also need to add on.
We need to consolidate the local mayors.
And that's what we did.
We have an association
movement that I've initiated
of local mayors.
Most of them are independent,
but we stick together because if we don't,
there will be either threatened
by peace or both by peace,
or they will simply stop engaging
in national politics, right?
And this is again, coming
from my presidential campaign
because in many places,
I was there and the
local leader was with me.
And that's why my result was so good.
I'm gonna give you one example
from east and southern Poland
and why I lost the election.
First of all, there was
no even playing field,
but one of the reasons is
that in our strongholds,
we get 70%, and Peace
gets 30 in the big cities,
in their strongholds, in
the eastern and rural areas.
There are in Potaszniki, in
many counties, I got 10 or 15
and Duda got, the president
of Poland, got 85% or 90%.
There's one county in Powait Carpach,
where there is a mayor who
used to be a cop in Warsaw.
And he went and he said to the priest,
I mean, if you keep on preaching
politics from the pulpit,
you're not going to help
renovate the church.
Stop it, okay?
You keep on talking about Trzaskwski.
It was because of Warsaw
that after the flood,
Warsaw, as a sign of solidarity,
they paved the roads and they help us out.
And don't believe those lies
about him trying to
change the way we live.
I know him, he has a respect for tradition
and so on and so forth.
In this county, I got 35%, okay?
Impossible to win, but 35 not 10 or 15.
And when I go there, they tell me,
I mean, if you come in your political hat,
it's gonna be difficult.
If you come as a mayor great, no problem.
And thirdly, we've done a
campus Poland initiative
where we invited thousand people,
young people from all over
Poland, socially active.
And for a week, we were
talking about the topics
that they wanted to talk about.
So, they wanted to talk
about women's rights,
global warming, artificial
intelligence, and so on.
And we were talking about,
I was there for a week.
Many of them were afraid
that we were going to indoctrinate them.
No, it was an open debate.
And many of my colleagues were there.
We invited politicians,
we invited experts,
we invited rock stars.
We were having concerts.
We were having sports activities
and we've created an
alternative grassroot movement
and a network which works.
And now when I go to (indistinct)
okay, of course, I'm
meeting with Platformer,
but that's not enough.
Because they're convinced people,
but I'm meeting with the local leaders
and I'm meeting with the young people,
and they're local.
So they tell me,
those guys they will
vote for Peace forever.
You can of course, talk to them,
but be aware.
These guys are yours.
So say hi, but don't spend time
because there are Platformer guys.
Those are the guys you
need to be the convincing.
So what I'm saying is that
I am absolutely convinced
that the opposition parties,
first of all, we all
have to be more mature
and we have to collaborate
and start trusting each other.
That's very important, but we
have to build a bigger tent
and do what populists are doing,
try to reach out and talk to the people
who are not convinced.
And by the way, the campus thing,
80% of the people had
nothing to do with politics.
There were political in a
sense that they were active,
but they were not party political.
Many of them, I hate my party.
Some of them, not many, but some hate me,
but they were there.
And we had bounced ravage there.
The founder of the shock therapy.
For half of the young kids, he was a hero.
He was God.
For half of them, he was devil reincarnate
because they were from the left.
You should have seen the discussion.
Whoa, I mean, how hard it was.
And Andrezej was like this,
because he's God at his university,
it's not like he was
asked difficult questions.
And guess what?
They were pushing politicians
who were very cautious.
Some of my friends to
be much more courageous
because they were pushed so much.
And the politicians are not
that used to having an open room
and having hundreds of questions
and then they need to answer them.
So, I mean, that's my only answer.
Talk to the unconvinced,
do the grass movement,
be with the people.
And that's a lesson from being a mayor,
because you are just accountable.
You walk the streets and all
the time you are ask questions.
No other question, no other answer,
but I remain hopeful.
- Do we have time for another question?
Okay, yes, please.
- My name Desta, I applaud you
I'm as part of being Polish.
I know Polish love refugees so much.
My question for you as a mayor of Warsaw,
I know that sometimes started
saying comes April 1st.
They will stop helping the big expo places
to have place for Ukraine refugees,
and they decrease amount per day,
how much they spend on immigrant refugee.
I know that the good weather is coming.
A lot of motels, hotels are
gonna need the tourist money.
What is the immediate plan for Warsaw,
you as a president and for other cities,
according to help the refugees
and relocate up somewhere else?
- Great, two more questions and...
- I'm Trakoswki,
and Mr. Trzaskowski,
I would like to know
from your perspective,
how the whole crisis,
I mean, coming back to your question also,
how this crisis will actually
impact the budget of Warsaw
and what is your plan?
What are the counter measures
that you would like to take,
given the non-cooperative
government that we have?
- Wonderful, both great questions, yeah.
- Thank you for coming, Mayor.
My name is Victor, I really
noticed in your lecture,
the current government Polish government
has experienced an incredible
turnaround in its public image
and international standing
just the last two months.
So from an outlier marked
by rule of law issues,
abuse of gay and women rights,
challenging international investors
in their property rights,
and a very damaging reaction
to the U.S. presidential election, 2020,
they became a strategic
partner of Brussels
and Washington celebrated for a generous
and courageous response
to concurrent prices.
All that in just a months.
My question is, do you
as one of the leaders
of the opposition that has
been fighting those abuses
for the last seven years,
feel like the government is
getting passed from the west?
It's been that of the hoop essentially.
- My job is that they don't.
Well, I mean, of course,
the most important thing
is that we solve a problem,
and I'm collaborating
with this government.
And when it's below the radar,
sometimes it's even a
good corporation, okay?
But of course, they're pushing
most of the responsibility
our way.
And they promised the money
and it's going to be
like with the pandemic.
That at the beginning
we were collaborating
and then they were pushing all
the responsibility our way.
And they were taking money away from us.
And one day were saying,
I'm responsible for 11 hospitals.
One hospital needs to be COVID.
Okay, fine.
And then they say, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no,
all of your hospitals need
to have a COVID ward, okay?
Okay.
And then they suddenly set up a hospital
at the national stadium
and they pay all the
doctors three times more.
So, all the doctors start working there
and they don't have enough equipment.
So when there's a serious case,
all of those guys come to me, okay?
That's a lack of strategy.
And that's what I'm
afraid is going to happen
this time around.
So, I don't have my
own relocation strategy
because we need a relocation strategy,
not only on a national level,
but on a European level.
Okay?
And I am telling the government
exactly what you've just told us.
And I'm telling all of my friends
in the European Union, in America,
that this is going to end.
We cannot do it indefinitely.
That's why we need to
have a relocation scheme.
That's why we might need
more reception centers,
created by the UN agency
who know best how to do it.
We don't have to invent a wheel.
We have all of those guys on the ground,
but they're just not authorized to work
because there is no coordination.
And there is no call for help.
There's no memorandum understanding
between the central government and them.
And that's what we need because of course,
we are retrofitting office spaces.
I decided to keep those tents
even though now we don't have
an influx of refugees open
to prepare for a second
wave, but what can I do?
I can prepare for 10,000
people, 15,000 people.
I cannot prepare for another 100,000.
And what if many people will simply say,
okay, I cannot accept Ukrainians
any anymore at my home.
Okay, now of course, there's a problem
with those hotels that
you've mentioned and so on.
That's why we need strategy.
That's why we need help
from the European Union financial help
and relocation strategy, okay?
Now, when it comes to the
government washing their hands,
and I mean, first of all,
we need to keep the pressure on those guys
also for security reasons,
because we need to be a strong democracy.
And I know, and that's...
I told that to President
Biden, when I had a chance,
I told that to secretary
Blinken and they know it.
I've told that on the hill,
I'm telling that all my European friends,
so that they need to remember that.
And I also give them ready made recipes.
I tell them, listen, if you
are connecting your money
with rule of law, you put me
in a schizophrenic situation,
because I cannot say that
I want the money to be...
I don't want the money to be blocked.
See, I'm so used to propaganda
that I don't even say the sentence
which can be cut out of context.
So I don't want the money
to be blocked of course,
and frozen, but they need to
be tough on the government.
So I tell them, so give a
bit of money to us directly
to the local governments.
It's as easy as that.
It's a win-win.
Populist do not win cities.
Make a huge program that
takes away diesel power buses
from the streets of European cities
and give them directly to the
cities which are ambitious.
By the way, Warsaw was just announced
one of the hundred green cities in Europe.
We are in it, okay?
Again, a bit of direct financing.
That's what I was fighting
for for the past three years.
So there are solutions
and that's what I'm telling
our American friends.
Most of them understand
it, but many of them,
especially in Europe, would
want to use that as a pretext,
because they are fed up with having to ask
the peace government about it.
But it's the job of ours, the
job of also public opinion
to keep on pushing and to explain.
And that's like to my American friends,
that's what I'm saying.
I'm not telling them all
values, values, values,
because although Ukrainians
are actually dying
for those values now.
They're dying exactly for the
values that are undermined
in some of our countries.
But I tell them that
they need a strong ally.
They need a credible ally.
They need a democratic ally.
They cannot afford...
No one can afford Poland
to be now a weak democracy.
So this is an incredibly important issue.
And that's why this pressure
needs to be kept up.
And that's why it is so
important and hopefully,
I mean, this is not going to...
And most of my colleagues,
most of my interlocutors understand that.
Honestly, there hasn't
been such a strong effect
of rallying the flag as
some people expected.
So that gives us hope that
at the end of the day,
people polls, when it comes to elections,
that they will take the
right decisions, okay?
And that they will not forget
about what this government
was doing.
Okay?
And it's also of course our job
to make sure that happens.
Okay?
Did I omit any question?
I think I've answered yours.
Yes.
Okay, I think I addressed
all the of questions.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, guys.
Yeah, I think, yes.
- [Man] (indistinct).
You know it's up to you.
I mean, I can still answer lot.
- [Listener] There actually two.
So like one I will summarize
because people are like...
- Sure. Shoot.
- So for first question,
regarding LGBTQIA plus
community rights in Poland
and how you see their
future in Polish society,
regarding current events
and within the internal policy of Poland.
And the second is more grounded
to what's going on right now
that the suggestion is
that many Polish people
are going to be affected by
(indistinct) of the guests.
And who that will be and what
will be the repercussions.
- Oh, and last question.
- (speaking in foreign language)
Have a question that
maybe a broader question,
back to the point that
you've been really stressing
about the need for strategy.
So, if we talk about European strategy
in the wake of the war in Ukraine,
or well, it's not really in the wake
because the war's still going on,
and I would love to get your thoughts
about broader geopolitical
dimensions or strategy
that is European Union's
policy or strategy
on relations with Russia.
What are key components of that strategy
that you would like to see in place?
That's one,
and I'm asking that in addition
to leading European countries,
leading themselves of fossil fuels
and especially Russian fossil fuels.
So, what are some of the
other important components
of such a European strategy?
And I guess a second question
is who should be deciding it
and how should this strategy be decided?
Can you think of what according to you
would be a good mechanism
of arriving at a viable
and productive European strategy?
Of course, ideally one that
is free from Hungarian,
NITO and things like that nature.
- Well, I mean, there is no
other place to make a strategy
by the European council
where all the heads of governments meet,
and that's the place
to establish a strategy
according to the treaties.
And of course, there just
needs to be enough pressure
on the Hungarians and all
the others not to water down.
This is the most important thing.
And of course, the important
thing is to keep up sanctions
in place to strengthen Europe
when it comes to its defense
and security dimension.
To yes, to make Europe
independent of fossil fuels
and speed up the transition.
And also to do it in a way which is smart,
to offer a serious perspective
to Ukrainian and to Moldova
when it comes to the membership
of the European Union.
At least those two countries,
but speed up the accession.
And of course, to adopt a common policy
when it comes to displaced people
and have a relocation scheme,
because this is immensely important.
So, most of the elements
of the strategy are there,
it's now just a question
to get them together
and to put them together.
And not to allow anyone to
water down as simple as that.
or as difficult as that.
And know...
Yeah.
- [Female] When you say stronger military,
do you mean within the structures of NATO
or outside of the structure?
- Both, I mean, we have
the structures ready
because we do not want to duplicate NATO.
And after the Warsaw summit,
we know how to strengthen NATO,
but also strengthen
the European dimension,
which is part of the same
system as if a second leg.
There is no talk about the competition,
but for example, all the
things that now we are doing,
like providing lethal weapons,
I mean, it was unthinkable
a few months ago
that you could do it.
Now, it's just a question
of better coordinating it.
And of course, part of that strategy
also is not only a
European Union strategy,
but NATO strategy.
For example, we do not do rotating basis,
but permanent NATO basis
in Poland or in Romania
or in the Baltic States,
because of course, there is
also security dimension to it.
Now when it comes to
gas and we are for now,
we are prepared also because
of most of the things
that we've done under the energy union,
but of course, that needs
the reliance of the system
and of our allies, which
needs providing us with gas.
And of course,
we need to prepare for
the more difficult months
and we need European solidarity.
It was announced, but now we
need to put it in practice.
And also the international solidarity,
we are finishing the connections
with the Norwegian fields,
but of course, we can
import gas from the U.S.
and so on and so forth.
I think that President
Biden just yesterday,
indicated referenced it.
So, let's hope that we'll
go into that direction.
And again at the end of the day,
it is peace governing in Poland.
And of course, we have
inflation everywhere,
but more so in Poland.
And this is because of
some crazy decisions
of the central bank,
which is in the hands of the peace crony.
And of course, we need to
also explain to the people
that most of the all of the
decisions were taken by peace
and that they need to be held accountable
at the elections that are coming.
And the last but not
least, the LGBTQ community.
I mean, these guys, the
peace guys, the government,
the Polish government was trying,
they always need to have an enemy.
And I think that they've used
because of my presidential campaign,
they've used all kinds
of arguments they could
in order to attack me, to
attack the LGBT community.
And I think that they went so far
that they've just ridiculed themselves.
I'm just gonna give you one example,
because not all of you have
followed the Polish politics,
I've signed the LGBT
charter as the first mayor
and I'm now the only mayor
in Poland to help out
the LGBT community.
And we've said that in this document,
it says that we are going
to use the WHO standards,
World Health Organization as a benchmark.
What the Peace propaganda did,
they took a booklet from WHO
written by experts for teachers,
explaining how children develop,
that they get interested in
their bodies with their age
and then they start masturbating
when they're 12 and so on.
And for three weeks, they've
unleashed this campaign
that I want to teach masturbation
to children at school.
And that was like the key
argument that they had
throughout the campaign.
And of course, everyone
in Warsaw and Poland
cracker was laughing
like you are laughing,
but in the rural areas,
they were not laughing,
but they've went so far
that now when I go and
travel around Poland
and I talk to people, they
know that it's just not true.
Okay?
So of course, we will keep on
defending all the minorities.
And by the way, I'm not a crazy leftist
as they try to portray me.
I'm just this my job as a mayor.
If someone gets by and is
successful, my job is not to medal
because they get by.
And if I have people who have problems
or they're marginalized or attacked,
my job is to help them
because I'm a mayor.
And it doesn't matter whether
they're senior citizens,
people with disabilities, LGBT minorities,
all kinds of minorities,
we are there to help.
And that's a normal standard
of a democratic country.
And I think that we were
driving that point home
all the time.
And I hope that we are in a
different place when it comes...
I mean, it will be very difficult,
again, to unleash this campaign.
People have heard all the arguments,
and they look around and nothing changed.
I still have two kids, same
wife and a dog and a parrot,
(participant laughs)
and our way of life is not threatened
because we've signed an LGBT Charter.
And we say that we should be
protecting everyone's rights
and that's the foundations
of the democratic society.
So, I think that...
And many people say that I lost
the election because of that
and so on and so forth.
But at least, people saw
that there are politicians
in Poland who do things
that they believe in.
And that's worthwhile in itself.
And we've opened doors to
start discussing subjects
that maybe were taboo for a while.
By the way, not easy anywhere.
When was the judgment of the Supreme Court
of the United States
on same sex marriages?
2015?
It wasn't 50 years ago,
and don't get me started.
Okay.
So, I mean, it's not that
we have our variants,
or we don't understand
that sometimes we hear.
We just need people with guts
to start debating these things
and explaining to people that
this is what we should do.
This is the right thing to do.
And on top of that, explaining
that there is no ideology,
there are just people and no ideology,
and that no one threatens our way of life.
Look at the European Union.
I mean, we collaborate, we
build a community together
and it strengthens our national identity.
Doesn't weaken it.
And it strengths not
only the French identity,
but also the identity and Pole identity,
also Kasian identity in Poland.
That's what we should be doing.
And do you see, I don't
know, Italians from Florence,
like fretting about it,
or I'm gonna lose my Florence identity.
I will start speaking, I don't know,
with a Roman accent because
of the European Union.
No, okay?
I'm not losing my Polish identity.
I'm not losing my Warsaw identity
because I'm also European.
And we need to drive
that point home, okay?
And I think that either you have guts
to start these debates, or you don't,
but I hope that we've started
these debates in Poland.
And now we just need to hold
this government accountable.
Okay?
And here I'm finishing, we
need to keep the pressure up.
Okay?
Because if I see that
in a Ukrainian crisis,
one of the NGOs, which
got the biggest support
from the national government
in Poland is Mr. Bulgeich,
a crazy fascist guy who's organizing
those marches around Warsaw,
which George of my city and these guys
are sometimes pronouncing words
which are simply racist and so on.
And they got support
because they've accepted
some Ukrainians.
And they've millions from the government,
millions of support.
And then I talked to an NGO, LA Strada,
who is fighting with women trafficking
and with forced prostitution.
And they tell me finally, we can work.
And I said, "What happened?"
And I said, "You support us,
but we got this additional grant
from American donors,
$5,000, and we can work."
Okay?
And here I'm driving point home.
I mean, please go and spread the message.
NGOs in Poland need support, okay?
Local government needs support,
volunteers need support.
And even if the credit goes
and then suddenly everyone
loves the United States,
fine, let them love him, but help us.
Because at the end of the
day, what you see in Poland,
it's not a miracle.
It's just solidarity and
it is the civil society.
It is the non-government organization.
It's the charities who do that.
And that's why we need to help them.
And that's why I'm not in a junket,
but I'm trying to convince
the American public opinion,
the donors, the NGOs,
the political foundations
and so on,
that we all need to get our act together
and that we should not lose focus
from the state of democracy in Poland,
because Poland needs to be in
lynchpin of European security.
And at the end again and again and again,
Ukrainians are fighting
for our freedom too,
for yours too, guys.
And for the stability of
Trans-Atlantic Alliance,
and for the values that we are preaching
and we talking about, and
they're dying for them.
And at the end of the day,
remember that all the bad
guys in the world are looking.
So, we need to prove to them
that we are going to be tough
and united and we are
going to draw the lessons
and it's not worthwhile to start wars,
attack sovereign nations,
attack people, kill them,
rape them, because otherwise,
we are going to end up in a situation
like we end up in Warsaw
and of course, in Ukraine.
Okay?
So, that's why we should
be spreading the message.
And if you tell me, will the world forget?
Maybe, but it's our job guys, yours too.
Some of you are Polish, Lavtian,
some of you are Ukrainian,
but many of you are American.
Just go out and spread the message.
And come to Warsaw, it's not a war zone,
help us out, leave a lot of money.
(audience laughs)
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
(soft music)